un paso atrás por precaución el estado
de california le impuso una medida que
obliga el uso de mascarillas en lugares
interiores
[Música]
hemos identificado 48 casos en
california esto es importante y una
mayoría abrumadora mayoría ha sido
completamente vacunada y es por eso que
el uso de la mascarilla se vuelve más
importante a este entorno warning and es
el bayern la restricción había sido
levantada en julio debido a una
reducción en los contagios y las altas
tasas de vacunación la medida se
mantendrá hasta el 15 de enero y forma
parte de una serie de iniciativas para
prevenir la propagación de omicron en el
estado el primero de diciembre el
gobernador de california anunció el
primer caso de la variante omicron en
esa entidad que cuenta según cifras
oficiales con más del 80% de la
población vacunada con al menos una
dosis entre tanto las autoridades
sanitarias de la unión americana no
descartan que omicron pase a ser la
variante dominante en las próximas
semanas
aunque delta continúa circulando
ampliamente en eeuu omicron está
aumentando rápidamente y esperamos que
se convierta en la variante dominante en
eeuu y en otros países hemos visto casos
de omicron entre los que están vacunados
y reforzados los bucks y néider al
booster estados unidos es la nación más
afectada en el mundo por contagios de
kobe 19 con más de 50 millones de casos
siendo la ciudad de los ángeles ubicada
en california la que presenta el mayor
número con más de un millón y medio de
casos confirmados por eso allí también a
partir de este sábado los empleados de
este estado deberán presentar su prueba
de vacunación incluso los policías